when Puerto Rico was suddenly on
everyone's minds after Hurricane Maria
one question kept coming up what does it
mean to be a u.s. territory Porto Rico
is just one of many US territories
including the US Virgin Islands American
Samoa the Northern Mariana Islands and
Guam but many Americans hardly ever
think about them most members of
Congress they couldn't find WOM on a map
and they don't want to because it's
completely off the radar the four
million Americans who live in these
territories can serve in the military
but they can't vote for president each
territory has one representative in
Congress but that representative
can't actually vote either US
territories are essentially American
colonies there's a footnote attached to
America's Empire and it's called Guam
way out in the western Pacific this
island of a hundred sixty thousand
people is the farthest west you can get
and still say you're on American soil
and since it's close to Asia it's the
perfect location for a US military base
which is why the military controls more
than a quarter of the islands land in
this series of untold America I'm gonna
take you to Guam I want to know how it
became and stayed a u.s. colony
driving around Guam you can't miss that
this is America you can hear planes
taking off from Anderson Air Force Base
tourists shoot guns at Wild West style
ranges and snap photos in front of a
replica of the Statue of Liberty but
like the other territories Guam is not
fully American since Guam is considered
a possession of the US but not part of
the US the Constitution doesn't apply
and so even today we still do not have
the full applicability of the
Constitution that's because of a series
of decisions called
the insular cases so the US Supreme
Court right the highest court in the
land basically in 1901 decides that
based on race based on this idea that
these places are populated by quote
alien races the Constitution wouldn't be
applied basically alien races are
incapable of understanding anglo-saxon
principles in guam's case by alien races
they meant the indigenous tomorrow
people who have lived on the island for
more than 3000 years before the
Americans came in Guam had already been
colonized for hundreds of years by the
Spanish then with the Treaty of Paris in
1898 the United States took control of
Guam the Philippines and Puerto Rico now
when they took Guam they declared the
entire island to be the Naval Station of
Guam and what that would mean for the
Chamorro people was that the military
ruled our lives and there was no
consideration of civil rights for the
people political rights it became a
dictatorship the Chamorro people were
denied the right to citizenship and
banned from speaking their language this
continued for decades until the United
States of America was suddenly and
deliberately attacked
by label a lay-up portion of the Empire
of Japan just hours after the bombing of
Pearl Harbor in Hawaii in December 1941
the Japanese also bombed Guam they had
actually evacuated all of the white
wives and children to the mainland
because they were expecting the Japanese
to bomb the island right and and I
mentioned white wives and children
because they didn't evacuate the
Chamorro women who had been married to
Americans the Japanese occupied Guam for
two and a half years during the war it
was a really traumatic time for
tomorrow's on the island I wanted to
hear from people who lived through it
the time was only like 11 years old who
also scared during occupation many women
were assaulted by Japanese soldiers Susy
was one of them I ran to the mango tree
on the mango tree and the Cypress trees
knocked this get their underwear I'm
trying to hold me down
I'm scared I'm gonna die Susy was able
to get away but still has a scar on her
knee from the attack she lost four
siblings and an aunt during the war I'm
half Japanese my mom is from Japan and I
was there for a number of years yes I'm
also American I never learned these
stories growing up I didn't know any of
these stories growing up during the
Japanese occupation tomorrow people were
forced to work the fields to produce
food for the Japanese toward the end of
the war the Japanese became more brutal
killing tomorrow's and math and rounding
them up into concentration camps Suzy's
aunt died on the march to one of the
concentration camps when she couldn't
keep up she was beaten and thrown into a
ditch the largest massacre which
happened in the northern part of Guam
and Gigi over 45 men who were beheaded
it's just one day after another there
are a number of massacres that go on
thirty people forty five people all the
way leading up to a liberation day
for 17 days without let-up American
planes and ships assault the island of
Guam
the people who were there at the time
you can understand the relief the
excitement the sense actually of
liberation of freedom people felt same
[Music]
we're really blessed dear won't you
please come back I started to understand
why a lot of people on Guam especially
the older generation are so patriotic
but after the war morals were moved into
refugee camps and the military began
taking land all over the island the
property to the left all the way
practically to the ocean as it's my
family's property and what worried but
the military did is they just took it
from us Antonio's family was forced to
sign over 4,600 acres of their land the
US military and he says they were paid
less than 12 dollars an acre for it that
land became Anderson Air Force Base less
than ten years later the military took
another thousand acres from the Sablan
family to create the naval communication
station there were 200,000 military on
the island and the US military had just
basically gobbled up just vast amounts
of land probably close to 70% at its
peak over 100 installations all over the
islands just every branch of the
military was here tomorrow's who had
just survived a brutal war were coerced
into signing over their land by threats
the need to prove their patriotism and
fear of military backlash on average the
military paid only one dollar an acre
for the land
tomorrow's were feeling completely
powerless
gut-wrenching land was all they had
literally land was their wealth man was
what they gave to their children and
grandchildren as a result of liberation
but schmorl's become landless and many
of them become homeless and the Chamorro
has become the poor people of Guam after
decades of fighting for their rights
under American rule timorous were given
limited citizenship under the Organic
Act now that they were citizens the
military was legally required to make an
official payment for the land they took
but that didn't mean the payment was
fair Antonio's family got a single
dollar for all forty six hundred acres
taken to create the Air Force Base
almost everybody in one pretty much we
got nothing just so unjust Antonio who
had served in the military himself did
inherit a small bit of land but
throughout the 80s the military made it
very difficult for him to access it I
literally get accosted at gunpoint
numerous times when I am in my family's
land a barrel of an m16 on the back of
my neck laying on the ground because
they're trying to identify for they're
not properly legitimate person to be
there even though you had an ID card and
that said you were a landowner that's
great that's why I became so outspoken
and radical because what am i doing
identifying myself on my own home to go
to my own private property
Antonio helped form the group national
morale also known as tomorrow nation to
protest the military occupation of Guam
so we were blocking the road we actually
put a tent in the middle of the world
they were all pious like handcuffed and
they would be a bus bike up ahead and
they would take us and they put us
inside the bus as a result of the
protest the guard shack that checked IDs
on that road was eventually taken down I
was willing to you know confront
Americanos and died in the 80s after
hundreds of tomorrow's filed claims over
the unfair original payments for their
the US government agreed to pay up but
they paid what the land was worth in the
1940s 40 years too late
the Sablan family chose not to accept
the payment in protest today Antonio
runs a tourism business with some of the
land he has left but of the five
thousand five hundred acres his family
once owned that became military property
none were ever returned I am the victim
there the one that's enjoying the fruits
of our land and they should be paying us
billions of dollars in rent money for
utilizing as the most important military
outpost here in the Pacific with
Anderson Air Force Base to the north and
the Naval Base to the south the US
military now controls 27 percent of the
land on Guam because of guan's
complicated past I can understand how
the legacy of liberation lives on but
while patriotism on the island is still
strong there are people who are pushing
back against the military they say it's
time for Guam an American colony to
choose its own fate
[Music]
thanks so much for watching part 1 of
our series I can't believe I never
learned about the brutal history of
Japanese occupation on Guam and school
in the sex video we're going to go speak
to people in the military who can't even
vote for president and we're gonna talk
to people in the independence movement
don't forget to Like share and subscribe
for more of untold America